worthy Avengers we can bust arms dealers
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's a game all six domes are
gonna soon to snap my fingers it would
all cease to exist the end is near hey
everybody this is gonna be my Avengers 4
video all about what the title of that
is going to be so infinity war parts 1 &
2 were what we knew about a couple years
ago but then a while ago they said that
they were not going to be calling
Avengers for infinity War part 2 because
the story was going to be completely
different so we're gonna be talking
about very specific things from infinity
war careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the movie yet but this is just the
beginning of Avengers 4 Captain Marvel
and all the Deadpool stuff that's coming
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's still giveaway stuff
happening that I'll talk about at the
end of the video but now you kind of see
why I use those age of Ultron infinity
war mashup clips
we're in endgame now that up there is
endgame how are you guys planning on
dealing with that so Tony's start
talking about endgame is far back is age
of Ultron Kevin Feige confirmed that the
title of Avengers 4 is not Infinity
Gauntlet he's like that is not at all
what the title is going to be so given
what happened during infinity war the
complete Thanos arc him basically doing
what he did during the Infinity Gauntlet
comic book storyline means that they
might move completely past that with
maybe grabbing a couple of story beads
there was also that tag at the end of
the movie that said Thanos will return
meaning that Thanos would be an
important part of Avengers 4 so it's not
like he's gonna go off into the sunset
we'll never see him again the quote from
the writers of infinity war is actually
pretty funny too they say this is a
hero's journey for Thanos by the end of
this hero's journey
our main character our protagonist at
least in his case gets what he wants
even if the end is tragedy we wanted it
to be definitive to say oh my gosh
what's he going to do he's only got one
Infinity stone left I wonder if he'll
get the other one the Infinity Gauntlet
was charred after he used it but it
looks like the gem still worked just
fine so maybe they get a couple more use
out of it I think they just wanted to
show you that you couldn't just use that
an infinite number of times there's a
limit on the amount that you can wield
that power so maybe we get to use it
once more and then something happens at
the end of Avengers 4 to either scatter
the gems or shatter most of them so that
it's not reusable but because of that
age of Ultron and the infinity war Clips
Doctor Strange talking about we're in
endgame now Kevin Feige and the Russos
teasing that Avengers 4 will be the end
of this giant story that they've been
telling since the first Iron Man film so
was sort of the end of this first era of
Marvel films were moving into something
else so that's why - most likely titles
for Avengers 4 I think our Avengers the
end or Avengers end game they actually
said that they came up with the title
for Avengers 4 pretty early in the
process when they were breaking the
stories for infinity War part 1 & 2
that's also probably when they decided
that the story for Avengers 4 would be
so fundamentally different that they
wouldn't call it part 2 anymore and also
I think it makes it a little easier to
market the movie like people won't feel
like they're going to see the exact same
movie the Russos also said we do have a
name for Avengers 4 we're just not
announcing it and I think we came to
that name fairly early in the
development process it speaks to the
heart of the story and I think the heart
of the story is the idea that it's the
end of everything they've been doing the
last 10 years which is why in-game makes
a little more sense but if you haven't
read it there's actually a non canonical
Marvel story called Marvel's the end
where Thanos reboots the universe but
it's not because of Infinity Gauntlet
related stuff it has to do with
something called the heart of the
universe like Gomorrah is Thanos his
heart he finds there's a fundamental
flaw in the universe so the cosmic
forces try to stop him from doing this
but they can't he moves too fast he
becomes one with the entire universe so
like he is the universe effectively he
reboots himself and that's how he fixes
things
now Tom Brevoort said that that story is
not canonical but that doesn't matter
like they can pull inspiration and ideas
from anywhere they want to so it's not
like they're gonna be doing a specific
comic book story for Avengers 4 there's
gonna be cherry-picking details from the
Infinity Saga relative to Thanos's
character in the major / arc but also it
sounds like from some other places like
Avengers the end because no matter what
happens if Thanos is the one to
ultimately fix everything like he
realizes he's wrong or Iron Man wields
in Infinity Gauntlet and fixes
everything they have to effectively
reboot the universe to fix all the
things that they know has changed like I
think that's part of the idea of dr.
Strange's planned for it in title to
view alternate futures to see all the
possible outcomes of the coming conflict
how many did you see
14 million six hundred five Tony there
was no other way
we're in endgame now like the plan was
so horrific but it was the only way that
they could ultimately win they had to
let the Annis win snap his fingers erase
half of all life but that doesn't mean
that they knows isn't also going to be
the hero of Avengers four when you look
at it from a funny perspective Avengers
infinity war is kind of fan OSes movie
you could call it 'the anos infinity war
and that would be a more accurate title
Avengers 4 sounds like it's gonna focus
more on the Avengers characters but the
a nose is still an important part of it
otherwise they wouldn't have had that
tag Thanos will return because that's
what they used to put at the end of the
phase 1 phase 2 movies Captain America
will return Thor will return so they're
kind of twisting the knife a little bit
by saying that Thanos will return but
they're also implying that he might wind
up being a hero at the end of the day
even though he's still technically the
villain like he erased half of all life
even if he fixes everything if he's the
one to reboot the universe then he's
still an [ __ ] that deserves to die
but the whole idea is OE Saldana Gamora
said that she's coming back during
Avengers 4 we've making all kinds of
theories about how the Avengers can use
ant-man and the wasp powers to go down
into the soul world all the people that
were turned to ash we know they're
coming back because Black Panther and
spider-man are definitely coming back
because they're getting sequels so
therefore you can assume that pretty
much anybody that was turned to ash can
come back doesn't mean that everybody
that died will come back just the people
that were turned to ash the funny twist
with Thanos sitting looking upon the
grateful universe at the end of the
movie like he says is actually from the
end of the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline so that kind of already lets
you know that they're not going to be
doing the end of Infinity Gauntlet for
ventures for it'll be something a little
bit different but they spent so much
time trying to make fan o's seem like a
well balanced character during infinity
war not a mustache twirling villain that
it doesn't seem like Avengers four will
be so simple as the Avengers stealing
the gauntlet from him then fixing
everything so let me know in the
comments do you think that Thanos will
ultimately be the one to fix everything
a la Marvel's the end or do you think
it's actually going to be one of the
Avengers wielding the gauntlet like
Captain America or Iron Man having to
sacrifice one of the others to reboot
the universe again then they go on to
say Avengers Ford doesn't do what you
think it does it's a different movie
than what you think it is also the
deaths are real I just want to tell you
it's real and the sooner you accept that
the sooner you'll be able to move on to
the next stage of grief which is kind of
funny that they're telling everybody to
move on to the next stage of grief but
just let me know in the comments what do
you think the title of Avengers 4 is
keeping in mind that it's definitely not
Infinity Gauntlet / Kevin Feige what'll
happen is is I have new Deadpool I'm
posting next tonight but I do have a
whole bunch more Marvel Avengers videos
to post leave all your requests in the
comments below and I'll try to get
through everything in the next couple of
weeks there'll be plenty more that we
need to unpack and talk about for the
movies that are coming up especially
phase 4 there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on the video congratulations
to the winner from my last big video
Kevin Smith who I'm assuming is not the
real Kevin Smith please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post new
Marvel click here for my video for all
the missing characters and click here
for all my Easter eggs from the movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]